all right patricia and sam
sam where are you guys from originally
i'm from
clarendon arkansas
and i was originally born in new york
but raised in philippine arkansas so you
guys are from arkansas
anywhere near little little rock
about
four and a half
four and a half hours from little rock
oh see here
um you're far you're you're not in the
big city
small town all right
i'm from a small town too
and tell me about uh your childhoods uh
patricia how tell me about your family
well my family
are the people that like to
make money
they're cops and they're crooked
and
i was
sexually molested by my own father
and
i was
basically
raped by a person that
i looked up to as a
brother figure
until i
had a baby by him
when i was 12 years old
and
my childhood was basically in and out of
the hospital
because of
having a three-chambered heart
and
also
i'm told by the doctors
that i wasn't going to live until 28
days before before i was born they gave
you 28 days to live yes
how old are you now i'm 28 years old wow
a three-chamber heart i've never heard
that before
i'm
you're supposed to have four
but
i have three
i'm
missing the main
source of
your heart the ventricle the vesicle
and
so
yeah and i was 18 when my mother passed
away
and then
october the 24th is when my
father passed away
2019
which is
um
then right after my father died i had my
little girl
and
they decided that
i was doing something wrong which is i
knew that i was doing something right
i didn't want them to put a feeding tube
in her because it was giving her
problems
and then they called dhs on us saying
that i was
doing something
wrong with them
telling them to take it out
because it was making her sick
making her definitely sick
and right after
we got news from my sister
and my sister-in-law and my brother
stating that she had to have
surgery on where
they had the feeding tube
and that's when i said yeah i knew i was
doing the right thing
so
are you raising how many kids do you
have i only have two and are you raising
your kids
no sir i was a little too young to raise
my son
you were 12
i was 12 years old
and
it was kind of difficult
but he is somewhere
with family and he likes it up there
he's with your family yeah he's with
some of my family that is on from my
dad's side
but on my mama's side they cannot stand
and
some on my dad and some on my mama said
they don't like
him because of
he doesn't he's not made of money
they don't like sam they don't like sam
they don't like him period why is that
because he is one of those
couch surfers
sorta
likes to stay in one spot then gone the
next
dude rather you were worth who someone
who
they would rather for me to be with
somebody that is rich
and i'm not going for that because
i believe in
finding who you are supposed to be with
and sam tell me about how you grew up
my
part of my childhood i don't remember
because
i was traveling with my dad
he took me
took me away from my mother when i was
five years old
took me to
arkansas following
[Music]
my
grandparents his parents
how would you describe your childhood
abusive
the
lady my dad married my stepmom
she would
beat on me just about every day
over some stupid stuff
did you guys finish high school
i didn't
you did
i didn't i had a
bad football injury and
my dreams
of
completing school was going to
play for the arkansas razorbacks
but i had that football injury and it
ended my football career
so i just set the hell with it did you
get in school
football was my dream yeah
so you guys are living where you're
you're homeless now yes
how long you've been traveling around
homeless
i found you at the greyhound station
for
uh we've been in california for about a
week
but how long have you been traveling sam
i've been traveling for the total of six
years six years
and you'll just go from
state to state city
but at first i was just going to
colorado texas
oklahoma missouri
basically the bordering states of
arkansas right
but since i got with her
she said she wanted to travel the united
states so i said
let's get out of my comfort zone
of the bordering states of arkansas and
broaden my wings a little bit you spread
out yeah so you've been all over the
country
just um states
the furthest i've been is new york
okay i've never this is my first time
out west yeah
how do you guys support yourself
she gets a social security check every
month
but are you doing anything other than
that no
uh you said you were panhandling right
yes
yeah we do
panhandle when
we find a busy enough
spot with enough traffic
enough traffic that has money right
ain't no making ain't making no money
over here
yeah you're you're in a private town
where you're not going to make much
money panhandling you'll have to get out
outside of skid row
and you guys sleep where now
anywhere we can lay our heads you just
lay down the concrete or something yeah
it's got to be rough
i don't like it because of we
almost got our bags stolen from us last
night because somebody moved my head
and
you do not wake up
a
an indian
um
i'm masculine apache
so
i'm easy to wake up oh i see
how old are you guys
i am 26.
i'm 28.
and you guys are
you've been
a couple for how long
almost
four years married
only one year oh you're married yes sir
what do you
what do you think your future holds
where do you guys want to be in a few
years
i'm trying i'm trying to pursue
either a
youtube career
or a music career
i'm more so wanting to be a singer
because some because some of my friends
tell me that sound is just exactly like
loretta lynn
i was here right no
and are drugs a part of your lives
just marijuana
just what the doctors give me
prescriptions for your heart yeah yeah
and i also have a little bit of ptsd and
and i've also cut myself a little bit
yeah when my mom passed away
uh it literally
it killed me inside when my mom died
you're close with your mom
that was my hero
[Music]
my mom was everything to me
she tried to keep my dad from
doing everything that he did to me
my dad always wanted to molest me
just because i didn't do what he wanted
me to do
how long did that go on with your father
i was two years old when it started
and it didn't stop until i was 16.
and when he died i was
i didn't feel no remorse
[Music]
i didn't feel no remorse whatsoever
both of my parents are dead
but when he died
i felt so relieved
that when
we have one more less child molester in
this world
what do you guys worry about no
what are you afraid of finding your next
meal
you're just surviving day by day yeah
and i have and also have uh
i have class size
apple class glycemia i have to eat or
my sugar will bottom out
if i don't get nothing neat
and i've been thirsty
since i got here
well i'm gonna set you up
you'll be good for a while at least
all i want is a shower a bed
what's your biggest regret
my biggest great regret
[Music]
my biggest grit i've ever had
was meeting up with an ex-boyfriend
[Music]
and moving in with a person that
tried to take my husband away from me
you moved in with somebody that
why were you not moving in with your
husband
we were homeless on the streets of
arkansas
so you you
he tried to prevent fence me to
do something that it's ungodly to do
and i wouldn't go for it and
he
basically got into his head with it more
than he did me
i was strong-minded not to do it
but
that was my biggest grit what was he
trying to get you to do
he tried to get both of us to sleep with
him
and i didn't want to do it
i believe in god i believe in jesus and
i believe in everything else
and i don't believe in that threesome
stuff
i don't believe in it
that's just me
i'm a christian
do you prefer this
this lifestyle of
living on the road and
having very little responsibility
um
having to something more stable yeah
but
right now i just want to travel
because that's what i want to do before
i actually want to settle down and do
things in my life
we're going to travel
from here we're going to basically going
to go up the canadian border
and back down through down to
our final destination is going to be in
florida
you may want to reschedule that and go
to florida during winter and go to up
north during this warmer months
if you thought that out yeah
winter's right around the corner i know
how cold it gets up north yes it gets
cold up there
i've never been up there so well i have
on a school field trip
when we drove the greyhound bus to new
york city
it was very cold
it was honor students they got to go
i'm honored i'm an honor student you are
yeah
but i'm not smart anymore because of
what my ex-boyfriend did to me he kicked
me in the school
so many times i
lost the love a lot of disability of
reading and writing
i lost a little bit of
that that much of my brain
because of what he did to me
[Music]
and i
i forgive him
i forgive him for what he done to me
i won't i
i won't forget
but i forgive because ain't that what
the bible said
ain't that what the bible says
forgive and forget
you guys still have contact with your
families
no how about you sam i still have
contact with my mother
because she got into contact with me
when i turned 18
and i finally got my first facebook
she was the first friend request and
i don't know who she was
it had been over 15 years since i've
seen her
i finally met up with her when i was 20
23.
now 22. yeah you were 22.
i left i walked from little rock
to
upstate new york
took four and a half almost five months
i left
during
during the spring i didn't show up till
about winter
till mid this mid
late december
late november early december
is when i showed up
what would you guys say is the most
important lessons you've learned in your
lives
um
for me it would have to be respect
honesty
honesty and respect those are great
and
like him
[Music]
all right
patricia and sam thank you so much for
sharing your stories
and i wish you the best of luck with
your marriage and your travels
thank you very much
you